(upbeat music)
- We are back with Bowen Yang, everybody.
(audience clapping)
Sometimes we talk about our
obsessions on this show,
but while we're obsessed with many things,
there are also things
we are just not into.
And, which Bowen knows,
because he also talks about
things on his podcast,
Las Culturistas, which
we've been talking about.
I love it so much.
- Oh my God.
- So today in honor of Bowen,
it's time for a round of, "Kelly
and Bowen Can't Stand It."
(upbeat music)
♪ Kelly and Bowen can't stand it ♪
(audience cheering)
- Very specific.
- Wow.
- I like it. I like it.
- [Bowen] That's very funny.
- Okay, here's how it works.
We're gonna hit, I feel
like we should sing that
next time it hits.
- Yes.
- We'll hit the button
and our supercomputer
will search through our text messages
for the things that bother us most.
- Uh-oh.
- I know. Watch out.
Then, Bowen and I will get,
we're gonna get to vent about that topic.
So I'm gonna start, here we go.
(bell dinging)
- Litter.
(audience laughing)
Go.
- We don't mess around with that, y'all.
Like, you just don't litter.
It's just so
- [Bowen] We don't play that.
- [Kelly] Why?
- Why?
- Why? Yeah, it drives me
nuts. I get very angry.
- Okay, you're gonna be
a perfect New Yorker.
This is amazing to hear.
- But you better not let me catch you.
I will, Mama will go off.
- [Bowen] Yes!
- I will.
- [Bowen] Come on.
- It is something that drives me insane.
Does it bother you?
- Of course.
- Okay.
- And it's New York,
there is a trash can on
every corner, basically.
- Exactly.
- It's like there's no excuse.
- You're right by it.
- Yeah.
- Come on.
- Yeah, it'll literally be in front of it
and I'm like, are you fricking kidding me?
- [Bowen] Right.
- Yeah.
- This is actually so refreshing,
'cause I saw that word, litter.
I thought you were gonna talk
about kitty litter. (laughs)
- I'm allergic to cats.
- Yeah, there you go.
- Okay, it's your turn. You get to hit it.
- My turn. Okay. Wow.
- Okay. Okay.
(bell dinging)
- Cough drops.
- Wait, what?
- They don't work.
- [Kelly] No.
- They don't get down there.
They're just kind of clicking
and clacking around the teeth.
It's not getting to the throat.
It's not medicine, it's not candy.
What are you? Pick a lane.
- What are you? No, wait. (laughs)
(audience clapping)
Wait. I have the cough drops for you.
- Grether's Pastilles?
- [Kelly] No.
- Ricola?
- No, that's the
vocalist thing to do.
- [Bowen] That's right.
- No, but no.
I love, they're Thieves and
they're, it's the cough one.
- Okay.
- You know what it does
if you have a cold, it
opens up your sinus.
It's very, I'm telling you,
you're gonna love them.
- Oh, so have I been just
getting it wrong this whole time?
- You've been buying the wrong ones.
- [Bowen] I've been buying the wrong ones.
- Yes.
- And I'm thinking they're
supposed to go down, but
they're supposed to go up.
- No, they're supposed
to just help out overall.
It will help clear out your throat.
- [Bowen] Okay.
- I literally,
in Vegas sometimes, I live
with them in my mouth.
Sometimes I've choked on it
on stage, but I don't care
because it opens up your, it's nice.
- If that's the way you go.
- Yes.
- If you choke
on one of these, then
I'll hate them even more.
I'm not gonna like them.
- I'm gonna hate them even more.
Okay, wait. I'm gonna hit.
- [Bowen] Okay, your turn.
- I'm gonna hit. I'm
gonna get you some. Okay.
(bell dinging)
(Bowen gasps)
This is childhood trauma right here.
I can't, I will read a page 1,000,
I can read fast actually.
I love speed reading.
Not as fast as my mother.
I'm like, "Did you read it?"
Anyway, but like, but I love it.
But if someone's watching me, I can't.
I read the same page over and I'm like,
was I reading it fast enough?
Do you think they're like
Like, I am so self-conscious.
- Right.
- I can't have people watch me read.
- It's vulney. It's vulnerable.
- Not like a teleprompter.
I mean, like, if I'm reading, like, a book
or like, if I'm reading a script
and I get nervous about
people watching me read.
- You're on display. You're on display.
Right.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- No, you might as well be on the toilet.
It's so vulnerable.
- Which I do read a lot. (laughs)
- Yes, it's a perfect place
to read, but it is like, it's
- It's where I check my emails.
- Yes. Perfect place.
- Yes.
- Sanitary too.
- Exactly.
- But you're so in the zone when you read
that, like, my jaw's probably like,
like, agape.
Like, I don't want people looking at me.
- I just get nervous like kid
at the chalkboard, you know?
- Oh, come on.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Oh, that's so heartbreaking.
- It's sad. It's fine.
Okay, one more for you.
- I have one more?
Okay, here we go.
- [Kelly] Yes, you have
one more.
Let's see.
(bell dinging)
Baby's Breath.
- Wait, what?
- The flowers, not breath from a baby.
(audience laughing)
Okay.
But I'm gonna take this
opportunity to drag babies,
like, actual breath of babies as well.
(Kelly laughing)
They're the most pathetic little flower.
They don't do anything.
They don't add anything.
- Well.
- And why are we
calling flowers that?
Because have you smelled a baby's breath?
Not great.
- I don't know.
I have a thing with babies.
I do love babies, like, their breath.
I do puppy breath. Like, I love all that.
- Oh.
- I do.
- I guess I'm just a bad person.
- Yeah, no, you're not.
I just like weird smelling
things apparently.
(Bowen laughing)
No, I do.
But I like the language of
flowers. I'm very into that.
And so I like that it
represents, like, who,
I don't usually put it in a bouquet often
because it represents
like, you know, innocence,
and purity and I don't know
a lot of those people, so.
(Bowen laughing)
All right, that is "Kelly
and Bowen Can't Stand It".
But you're welcome.
We have moved just so
many people with that.
(Bowen laughing)
Bowen's movie is called
"Dicks: The Musical".
It's in theaters now.
I just like saying it.
And tomorrow night, you
can catch a brand new "SNL"
on NBC and Peacock with host
and musical guest, Bad Bunny.